c'est sans doute l'un des plus grands
scandales de cette crise du coronavirus
la gestion des masques serait-elle
devenue le symbole les déficiences du
gouvernement en matière de sécurité
sanitaire
pour nous c'est un véritable scandale
d'état ces masques comme tous les
masques chirurgicaux aurait dû être
commandé le plus tôt possible
gouverner c'est prévoir quand la crise
sera finie
nous espérons que certains responsables
qui ont été incapables d'organiser la
défense sanitaire du pays auront à
répondre de leurs actes devant la
justice
que s'est il passé comment en est on
arrivé là
pour comprendre il faut revenir aux
racines de la crise début 2001 le 26
janvier très précisément agnès buzyn
encore ministre de la santé se veut
rassurante
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune indication à
acheter des masques pour la population
française et d'ailleurs nous avons des
dizaines de millions de masques en stock
en cas d'épidémie ce sont des choses qui
sont d'ores et déjà programmées fin mars
en pleine crise du coville 19 alors que
la france est confiné les conseillers du
premier ministre edouard philippe
découvre que depuis plusieurs semaines
des millions de masques et sud des
réserves étatiques ont été
consciencieusement à brûler matignon
fait aussitôt stoppé le processus et 85
millions de masques sont sauvés in
extremis
ces destructions de masques ont été
décidées à la suite d'une expertise
commandée par santé publique france est
menée en 2018 par une entreprise belge
qui avait considéré que ces masques
étaient non conformes mais benoît valais
l'ancien directeur général de la santé
qui a lancé cette expertise et cimc en
réalité une partie conséquente de ses
masques même ancien aurait pu être
utilisé une part substantielle des 616
millions de masques datant de 2005 2006
aurait sans doute pu être mises en
circulation
d'ailleurs il ne portait pas de date de
péremption et son successeur à la tête
de la direction générale de la santé
n'est pas un inconnu il s'agit de jérôme
salomon ancien conseiller à la sécurité
sanitaire de marisol touraine et
conseiller santé des manuels macron
pendant la campagne présidentielle
jérôme salomon était-il au courant
risque de pénurie de masques oui si l'on
en croit une note confidentielle
destinée à emmanuel macron le 5
septembre 2016 la possibilité de
survenue d'un événement naturels
d'ampleur avec un impact sur un grand
nombre de personnes
des dommages matériels importants un
impact financier et d'image et des
capacités de réaction des passes et doit
être sérieusement envisagée anticipées
la france n'est pas prête
notre pays doit adapter ses
organisations aux spécificités des
crises majeures à venir
pourquoi jérôme salomon n'at-il pas tiré
les conséquences quand il est devenu
directeur général de la santé finalement
en pleine crise que rona virus et face à
la pénurie là encore la gestion de la
demande est catastrophique
les collectivités locales et les
entreprises passent massivement commande
auprès des fabricants français
problème l'état a aussi commandé des
masques en asie les français ont du mal
à écouler leurs stocks
le robinet asiatiques semblent s'être
réouvert donc aujourd'hui la situation
est catastrophique on en a 800 milles en
stock
je ne trouve pas les mots pour qualifier
cette situation totalement surréaliste
on a demandé un effort considérable à
notre profession pour se substituer aux
achats asiatiques
on l'a fait et maintenant on se retrouve
dans cette situation dramatique
destruction de masques encore
utilisables absence de prévisions et non
renouvellement des stocks de nombreux
points posent encore question
aujourd'hui la cour de justice de la
république chargé d'inscrire les plans
de liaison les actes des ministres a
déjà été saisie en ligne de mire des
ministres et leurs défaillances supposé
d'autres plaintes contre x ont été
enregistrés au parquet de paris
et tous dénoncent une gestion déficiente
de la crise sanitaire